up next is Kathy in San Francisco hi
Kathy how are you hi Dave I'm doing well
and thanks for taking my call sure
what's up well about 26 months ago I put
the brakes on and started to look at my
life in the debt that I was in and I
realized that I had to get moving to get
rid of it and so I read the Total Money
Makeover I picked up another job
tutoring I'm a schoolteacher I've taught
for about 20 years and I really got
focused and I wanted to be a good role
model for my children and I paid off
free eight thousand four hundred eighty
three dollars and 73 cents which was a
brand-new car credit cards and and money
for the kids for school Wow so I got
that done but now my question is I live
out here in California and I have a
house payment that's about that's two
thousand two dollars per month and I
take home regularly about forty three
hundred a month how did you pay off
forty eight thousand dollars in debt
extra money above that at that time I
tutored just around the clock I just
worked
numerous hour okay to do that well
you're going to be tutoring if you keep
this house right now and I just you know
what Dave I'm sixty and I don't want to
keep doing that maybe not around the
clock but there's just a me I understand
California real estate San Francisco
real estate in particulars unbelievably
expensive right and that there's a
reality that and people often ask me the
question if they're in Manhattan or LA
or San Fran you know well Dave I mean do
I get a pass no I mean California is not
exempt from math weight even though it
feels like it out there with the dadgum
house prices but still at the end of the
day after you pay your house payments
you're poor every month every month
you're happy my work yeah
and how poor is no fun it's not fun and
I so my plan my goal for myself is
hopefully to work five more years and so
I wonder do I sell it and rent for five
years do I sell it and try to buy
something smaller where are you going to
live after retirement
I you know what I'll probably end up out
here even though I don't really want to
be in California I'm a little confused
now why would you stay if you don't want
to be there my kids are here oh okay
okay and grandkids more importantly they
would probably yeah yeah if they believe
yeah yeah ah well um but you can't
retire in this with this house payment
right no I could not retire with this
house payment so I also got to go either
way the house has to go right yeah with
this income either the incomes got to go
up or the out guy who's got to go down
and that's what that's a fixed math
equation that we that we're just all
stuck with and so right yeah so I guess
I'm moving down in house that I'm going
to live in in retirement okay
and those you think look and maybe
purchase a smaller house if I okay now
something less expensive and that you
can afford and that doesn't make you
house poor and with the idea that we're
gonna a be able to afford it in
retirement and be eventually get it paid
off even in retirement right we got to
move in that general direction but yes
if you want to stay in the area let's go
ahead and do that now and create a
better living environment for you now
and then you know more opportunity to
save now because you make that move now
and it might just be a little condo or
something
that fits your lifestyle this is the
Dave Ramsey show